they tried shooting but the gun didn't
work apparently
and then somebody put a knife into
Reggie's hands
but he'd had a lot to drink he was on
tablets
on on purple arts and uh
Jen
I just totally off the wall we all went
down and you went down for murder I went
down Memorial yeah it's got 15 years
hello and welcome to extraordinary lives
a podcast from Lab Bible I'm Ben Paul
Jones and we're joined in the studio
today by Chris lambriano it's great to
have you here Chris it's not Suburban
for anyone who isn't aware of who you
are would you mind giving a brief
introduction yeah I was I've got many
roles
I'm a father
I'm a brother
I'm an uncle I'm a friend
and uh but I was arrested with the cry
Brothers
um in 1967
and I was sentenced to 15 years
for murder
um
and
it's something you can't get away from
when you do that kind of time
a man can get in a ring for 15 rounds
but it's over in the night
365 days a year for 15 years
and you never know when the day comes
you're going to get out or if you're
even going to get out because you're in
hell
and
I share my story in the hope that nobody
will travel down that road as I travel
down there
I I
looking back
I would say that you know there's so
many other roads that you can travel
that might be a bit harder
you have to work harder you'll have to
put more effort in but it's worth it at
the end of the day you'll see the
rewards you know just
don't give up
understood and you know it's a great
message when we get to the end of your
story I guess we'll hear how you came to
that thought process but for now let's
go back to the beginning of it you know
where did you start out what was early
life started out I mean
remember I um somebody who came up in
the water just after the war I mean I
can still remember going down good
Street Underground
when the bombs were dropping and the
sirens were going and stuff like that
and then we got evacuated up to stock in
Leicester right so what year were you
born Chris I was 1938 wow okay and uh if
stuck in this time my dad used to repair
the Spitfires and the airfields and I
always thought as a little kid being put
up in an airplane and sitting in a
pilot's seat that that's what I'd love
to have done but circumstances are
different we was up there and then we
moved back to London and there was a lot
of other people for everybody I mean the
East End West End no matter where you
look everyone was devastated bomb sites
and everything wonderful for kids to go
and play in and throw bricks around and
pull down buildings and stuff like that
I mean we didn't
life was what it was enjoy it that's our
attitude but the fact was I mean it was
highly just at the time if you walk on a
building so I know you go wear a yellow
hat in them days you didn't have nothing
we were kids just having fun and was a
sense at that time that England was back
in a state of like growth and prosperity
again after the war or was it very much
a sense of like every poverty poverty I
mean everything was Russian bananas but
the fruit sweets you know whatever it
was you had to have a Russian book
and but you know I we moved to a place
called 45 Matt Howland Street which is
just under the post office tower
and there were every kind of character
you could imagine Prince monologue or
I've got a horse
there was Yorkie a a guy who had an
awesome car used to go around collecting
junk and we'd go and go with him on it
on his journey round picking up old bits
of iron and because it presents scrap
stuff was everywhere and then from there
um I went to school down at uh in St
Patrick's in scios and
um Catholic School
but I somehow didn't fit in because it
wasn't like today when you go to school
you've got an education teachers knew
you and everything else it was upheaval
no matter moved from this place to that
place we finished up in a workhouse
either in South London and then from the
surf from from the workhouse in South
London we moved to the halfway house in
Victoria
and the way of earning Shilling when we
moved there was me and my brother used
to go and carry suitcases from a coach
station in Victoria down at the train
station and they'd give us a shilling or
six months or whatever and we could go
and buy different things we needed so
there was no problem of doing hard work
I mean it was what it was and then we
moved to the East End
was a different cut of fish
you know I mean
racism was pretty bad
I can remember going into one house and
they had a party there
and the lady of the house said
uh don't bring the great kid in
but I heard it
and I felt it you understand I'm a kid I
want to belong
I want to be a friends I want to be
running playing football what I want to
get out there I want to bum sites climb
and do whatever I don't want to be shy
out I've done nothing wrong I'm I'm a
human being
and uh that kind of attitude destroyed
me a little bit so were you a sensitive
kid yeah I was yeah yeah I was sensitive
to that time of thing and as I said then
we moved in the East End and uh
I just
I I went with some kids and we stole
some metal for Ruth
and I got sent to an approach or Barrack
basil Enriquez at Twin B Hall which is
just around the corner strange you know
um I went in front of him and he sent me
to an approved school and what's an
approved School proof school was where
you sent the naughty kids right where
more or less what they said was
that your parents couldn't control you
out of your parents control
and so they sent you there to learn
lessons
well when I went there
I went to school for maybe about
six months and then they put me to work
out in the fields
carrots picking carrots lettuce how old
were you here I would be about 12 and a
half 14. okay and I stayed there till I
was 15.
um and then I came out of there
and went home
but it wasn't long before
I got myself into more trouble
and then I found myself in a borsal
but then what I was doing was getting
into crime getting to meet all the
characters from all over England
because strangers it may seem
you know that there ain't many people
you don't know if you're in prison they
come from Liverpool Manchester
Birmingham Devon Cornwall all over the
place so you're connected up in all them
different places
and so I you know I did the approved
score and then I came out and I went in
the Army right and uh as a national
serviceman
and I went in in grade two so I went in
the pioneers
and because I've got perforated eardrum
I was a boxer in the in the postal and
they uh
you know I went in grade two and they
put me in a regiment in Wales pineapple
and uh it wasn't for me I'd already done
three years
in abort so I had all the discipline I
needed
and I just wanted to get out of there
and uh I I'd go and see a psychiatrist
and they turned around and said no
you know people have done your
kind of preschool boss or that kind of
thing you make good MPS
would you consider you know
going in into that kind of thing I said
no I wouldn't
you know I just want to go home I want
to get a job and
do everything right and so that's what
happened I went
back home
and um it
it all went pearshape again
and I want to watch a prison
so why did you go the second time the
second time I got done for blowing safe
right in a post office
and the in stone and that was
um and so I've got two years
and I did did the two years and I came
out
and I went looking for work but
I didn't fit in anywhere and were you at
that point in time were you attracted by
crime or was it just a mean to an end it
was a means to an end yeah all the way
through my life of crime
all I wanted to do was earn enough to go
straight
because I know that you know there is
there is no value in crime you've got
something now but you haven't got it
tomorrow you know it's it's like
gone
you spend it on this you spend it on
that oh I've got to have that I've got
to have this I've got to have that
do you really need it no you don't
but you can invest in yourself but not
only that if one thing now I'm 85 years
of age the one thing I can't buy it it's
time it don't matter if I was a
multi-millionaire
if whatever I can't go and buy any time
extra time I've got what I've got
could be today could be tomorrow it
could be 10 years from now I'm just
grateful for every day and so and you
know I I did
the first half of my life so I was I
came out of prison when I was 42. right
okay so my sentence finished I did the
15 years the full 15 years
and then I came out and
I wanted to change I wanted what I lost
so what was the 15 years for murder so
let's jump back a little bit there yeah
and then let's get certainly no no
that's okay so you did the you went to
prison for blowing the safe that's right
yeah came out from that yeah and then
was it a case that you then immediately
got back into the same song yes I did
yes straight away criminal yeah because
I didn't know anything else to be honest
with you yeah well that's the life I
knew yeah that's the culture that I'd
been brought up in the prison culture
as I said meeting people from all over
the country and so in many respects
that I didn't consider anything else
that's all I saw that crime was going to
be a way out and what what kind of crime
was it you were doing was it just
anything that came was anything that
came along like I said if you're
connected and we say are you you're a
pavement artist
now payment oh this is a man goes out on
a black
they go out they've got harmonia
or they've got a a what's her name uh a
shooter or whatever and it's a way
snatch
then you come away from there
you may be lucky you may get four or
five grand or whatever and but you've
got away with it and you've got a good
name in in that Circle that you can be
trusted you'll do your work properly and
you know you'll hold up you won't go to
pieces and then they'll tell somebody
else and they've got a bit of work going
well you're interested in this but it
wasn't something I really enjoyed to be
to be honest with you and what what
would you have done anything for money
at that point yes at that time I would
have done anything for money yeah and I
went up to Birmingham I was on the Run
and whilst up there I went to a
nightclub and there was a bit of a fight
going on and I jumped in about this guy
and he turned out to be one of the best
long-form men in the country
well what long firms are is they
open up the companies
and they get lines of credit everywhere
where they pay the credit
so they build up a good reputation with
these companies and then they go and say
look we need this
that might be twenty thousand that might
be fifteen thousand that might be ten
thousand and they get the goods which
they don't pay for
and then they sell them on
shut the office up and everything right
I mean the officers might be in great
Portland Street
maybe in good Street it may be in in
Piccadilly it might be anywhere
you can hire an office anywhere and that
basically is what the long firm is
and so but the other thing as well
there was also protection
[Music]
now people think that you walk into a
pub or you walk in a an off license or a
sweet shop and demand money with menaces
I'm protecting you it don't work like
that
they come to you oh really and say look
we've got a problem somebody's given us
some grief with being threatened or
whatever are you going so well
and the people you're talking oh they
know your main business
and so consequently they leave the
person alone
they don't need any grief all they want
to do is be able to come get some money
and go and do whatever they want to do
and so that's the way the Christ got
involved in all these different things
people went to them they didn't go
bashing people up and all that kind of
stuff it's
I mean the pornographic industry in in
in in Silo I mean all that they had
problems with different people
threatening them and everything else are
going to smash their shops up and you
want to sort out and they were happy so
they the the people with the businesses
would be threatened by people and they'd
go actively to The Craze to The Craze or
go to whoever
and there wasn't Only The Craze there
were firms that you don't even know
about
but they were more honorable they kept
things to themselves they're quiet these
people didn't even let their wives know
what they were doing because if the
police
to add a new idea that they were up to
something they'd gone pulled a wife in
and want to know this that and the other
threatened to take the kids off them and
everything else either so a man never
told his wife he never told people any
more than they needed to know that was
old school
and you looked out for each other
and so you know it it it was and I was
doing okay in Birmingham
you know I had my own car pitch I was
earning money
I was respected
I you know I gambling has just taken off
up there the car industry it was unlike
London
London was ripoff no matter what it was
if you wanted an ice cream you're going
to pay three times as much as you pay in
a shop
where in Birmingham everything was
normal it was the same you went to a
nightclub you had a good night hour no
problems people just went out they're
working hard they worked in the car
industry and one of the and gambling
took off
and people didn't want people kicking
off and smashing up their their casinos
and what have you so you looked out for
people
and they looked out for you and that's
the way it works and were you at that
point in time when you said you had your
own car pitch was that a legitimate
business
legitimate business side it was a I had
a car pitch but I also had a car wash as
well right so you sort of gone straight
at that point I I was going straight
going straight
um but what I used to do was come down
and see my dad I lost my mum she was
quite Young
and
um
you can't even imagine
what a family can feel
until they've lost a loved one like a
mother who loves them and they've felt
it
and it's like taking the caption the
ship away
this person who makes the cakes on a
Sunday Sunday dinner probably roast
dinner and then like makes the cakes for
later on with sit at a table people
don't sit at a table anymore
it's all about looking at a phone and
all the rest of it they talk to the
phone more than they talk to their
brothers it's their father and so we
live in a in a very strange world
but it was rapidly going that way you
understand what I'm saying that things
were taking over
and so you know when I lost my mum she
went up for the first holiday in her
life
my mum worked as an office cleaner of an
evening so she'd work from say seven in
the evening until maybe two or three in
the morning we might be my sister-in-law
in the city so you know she went away
for the first holiday and passed away
um
you just done that cope with that you're
off the rails you you don't believe in
nothing
you you you you you try to get your head
around it
but why would a loving God why would
somebody who you know created somebody
and prepare that person in that family
take them away when you need them more
than ever
she was the one kind of
you know stabilizing factor in our lives
and so you know that sent me
off the rails quite a bit and how old
were you here there I I was about 27
okay 26. and what happened then was that
uh I used to come down and see my dad
was okay every couple of weeks
and I came down
to see him this this week and um it it
was okay and we enjoyed the company
and I went back up to Birmingham and I
follow him Friday I was in the dolls
club and there was a guy called Ray
Mills there
and he said Chris he said
are you going down alone this weekend I
said no
he said Chris look come down he said
I've never met your brother you've never
met mine let's have a meet up and
whatever we'll have a a good time I went
no Ray I was down last week I'll go down
next weekend please Chris
and somehow rather you know you think to
yourself well it's I don't I don't do it
all the time I'll I'll go down again
this week and it was the worst move I
ever made
because I went down there
I'll go in touch with my brother Tony
and we met The Mills Brothers and we
went out for a drink
and we finished up in whopping
from mopping we went over to the pub on
the bethenal Green Road and uh
Twins were there the cries were there
was that the first time you said no no
I'd met him before now okay was your
brother involved with them my brother
was involved I never knew he was
involved right because what was
happening down here I really weren't
interested more interested in in my life
up there okay and um
I remember going that I'd meet a guy
called Connie White down at uh the blind
bagger and he didn't turn up
and consequently I went to get a bus
because my cat carves in the garage
getting serviced and uh guy called
Ronnie Bender came by and he said Chris
he said um
what are you doing now I said well I was
supposed to meet somebody in the bigger
and they're not turned up I'm catching
the bus home he said come on I'll give
you a lift and he gave me a lift home
and yeah thanks very much very nice to
see you again and keep his ex-soldier
xsas
you know really
strong market and no criminal record or
anything else either
and I kind of admired him because he was
he was he was a strong man
and he'd come out the Army been a
regular Soldier
and about an hour later knock on the
door is Ronnie Bender I said
he said
the twins want to see you I said running
out I'm going to see him
if you're short of a few quid you I'll
help you out but no
because
you knew what they were they were
trouble you understand what I'm saying
they
the grief they caused and everything
else like that so you didn't want to
were they famous at that point yeah they
were famous well they were kind of
famous everybody knew they were
and people knew that you know if
somebody had gone and committed a
robbery they'd want their little corner
of it right and things like that you
understand and were they in in terms of
the the criminal underworld at that
point in time were they intimidating
characters or were they just other
characters no no no they were quite
intimidating characters yeah
um and so
you know issue Chris is a Tony's down
there
and I couldn't say no Tony's your
brother yeah and I went down there
and perfectly polite
hello Chris nice to meet you
um
understand you up in Birmingham
um the reason we wanted to see you is
what a favor
and I said what's that they said well
we've opened a club in Birmingham uh in
Leicester and Charlie's running it and
we wonder whether you could bring some
people over
to gamble at our place
it's a nicely run Club it's a we'd like
to go and have a look at it assess it
and then decide if you want to bring
some punters over
as I shall I do my best and uh Charlie's
the older brother Charlie's the older
brother less famous in the general rest
of the pop culture but very amicable
very very kind of how can I put it
sociable
um
non-threatening or anything else like
that really decent old boy
and so the fact was I went back
and I went over I had a look at the club
I was quite impressed with it and I took
some people over there
and they were pleased and so other
people brought other people over there
so yeah it was all about you know
bringing the bringing the club to the
notice of other people and uh yeah it
was
it was it was okay then I've got to know
them a little bit better
and
I cannot put it
they
they wanted you to do things
mainly because I didn't live I weren't
under the radar
and so
a couple of things I did I wasn't happy
about
and can you go into them or or not um
well one of them was
they had a problem with a co-owner of a
club
and um
could you go and wake him up Chris
so I don't know nothing about the guy
but I've got his address I know where he
lives
in Coventry
and I went around there Sunday morning
I've got a desperate enough for it
through the windows
and I couldn't see he was in the room or
anything the curtains and that
and uh
as a man a woman and two young children
sitting there having breakfast
not me sideways I wouldn't have liked
anybody to do that to me I certainly
wouldn't have done done that I'd known
what was
what was occurring in that room
and uh
no I wanted I wanted away from
but going back to the night you know
they got that night we went to the the
pub and and and then went on to the uh I
wanted to go to West End and Tony said
let's go to the Regency Club
and we went to the Regency against my my
best wishes because Saturday night was a
Saturday night gangster night everybody
comes out all the working Lads you know
I want to be tough and all the rest of
it pretty impress the girls and uh so
you stay away letting them get on with
it and the West End was a better place
to go
and anyway we went there
General invitation to a party went round
and uh
we went to the party I couldn't get my
car out and uh we weren't inject to help
make British car and he he was a famous
character in that yeah or he is now yeah
he is now he wasn't then I mean right
Jack was a fun guy you understand what I
mean he it's all right people making him
a villain and this nasty person but that
wasn't a jack I knew you understand what
I'm saying it's convenient
paint him like that because
then it doesn't make the perpetrators
of his demise
bad people you understand what I mean
they got rid of a nasty piece of work
but
he had his differences with him and I
didn't know their business or anything
else like that and so we we go to the
party
Jack runs in the room
uh where's the girls where's the music
and all the rest of it people were
dancing and what have you and uh the
next thing a fight starts between who
between Jack and Reggie right so you'd
gone to this party on this night and the
creightons were in the party yeah that's
right previous to that Jack and the Kray
twins had issues with each other but
nobody knew it I'd seen in the previous
week I've seen Jack with Reggie and
everything was fine right
and Jack came and sat down with us he
saw him back on the farmer said didn't
even know he was on it right and so you
know I mean I weren't that connected to
him yeah to know what their business was
who was with him who wasn't with them
and so you know it it was what happened
so you you you were based in Birmingham
and you were doing the odd job for them
that's right kind of favors yeah that's
right and you'd come down for this night
out and you'd gone to I mean I never
earned any money from them oh right
really no no the only time they ever
gave me anything was Ronnie gave me a
watch
which he'd bought from what she's a
Switzerland picket in Piccadilly and it
was a Waltham I admired it and he gave
it to me just when it was that kind of
man
if you like something and he felt you'd
kind of done the return it could give
you something you understand what I'm
saying anyway the bottom line was that I
I
I didn't expect nothing of them when I
did that favor to go around the house I
never expected that so why would you do
those things
because they wanted rid of the guy was
he was he was a partner in the club but
why would you do them a favor if you
wouldn't get anything I guess as well
yeah but you
they do you five as you do then okay
okay what goes around comes around got
it you understand what I mean you never
know when you're gonna need them and
they don't know when you're going to
need you so they're good friends to have
it that's right yeah so that that was
what happened and so
I leave the party
and okay so oh sorry I just I'm back
just going back so you've gone gone into
the party this fight's broken and I'll
show you what happens I don't want to be
part of it I've had a lot of drink all I
want to do is go and Ronnie Craig comes
out and he says what's the matter
and I said I didn't come down there for
this
and he said that Connie White had take
him home
and Connie Whitehead took me home said
Chris don't go back there
I went in I had a cup of coffee with my
dad
sobered up a little bit
and I thought well my car is up at the
Regency I've got to go and get that
so I went up I've got my car from
outside the Regency Club
and I drove around the Reverend Road
thinking I'm going to pick Tony up
I don't know what's going on your
brother again my brother yeah I'll knock
at the door and Ronnie Bender comes to
the door
and I said to Tony they said no he's
gone
I said right wrong I see you later when
I walk away
he said Don't Leave Me
I said what do you mean don't leave you
he said they've killed him I said kill
do he said they've killed Jack no I said
not in front of all them people in front
of all them Witnesses I couldn't see
the possibility of it what was you can't
do that kind of thing
you understand because you're not only
dropping yourself in it but all the
people are there there must have been
about seven or eight people there so it
was it and blonde Carroll could come
back anytime who owned a house she
wasn't there
anyway I went in
and this is a soldier I'm talking about
a regular Soldier it a man you could
respect
and I went in we walked downstairs and
they're laying in the uh
by the fire was a body
and I looked and I thought he's going to
wake up in a minute
I can't believe
that
there's a dead man there
this episode of extraordinary lives is
brought to you by betterhelp now
sometimes in life we Face tough choices
those choices can make it difficult to
know the best path forward you might be
dealing with decisions around your
career relationships friendships or
something else whatever it is therapy
can help you stay connected with the
world around you whilst you navigate
through a more challenging period we've
worked with better helps him starting
this podcast and it's always led us to
talking about therapy amongst the team
it's something that often doesn't come
up in Daily conversation but it's been
clear that so many of us have benefited
from it therapy isn't exclusively for
people who've experienced major trauma
it's a really useful way of learning
positive coping skills how to set
boundaries and improve how you feel
about yourself and where you are in life
so if you're thinking about starting
therapy a good way to get into it is
better health better help is entirely
online so it's convenient flexible and
so to your schedule you just fill out a
quick questionnaire and you'll be
matched with a licensed therapist if
you're not clicking for whatever reason
you can switch therapists at any time to
try visit betterhelp.com minutes with to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com minutes with now back to
the show
um was that your first time seeing a
dead body yeah it was yeah right and I
just thought no it's gonna it's gonna
get up
and then you realize he's not
and so I went upstairs
and into a bedroom and I went to get an
idea down
because you can't we've got to move that
body yeah and um
I'll take it downstairs
but what I noticed there were two
children asleep in the bedroom upstairs
blonde Carroll had gone to another party
with her boyfriend George leaving the
two babies there
in in the care of the twins can you
imagine it
that
but killing somebody and there's two
babies upstairs
whether they knew they were there I
don't know
that's the jumble of it all Ben you
understand what I'm saying it
wasn't there's nothing saying about the
whole thing it was just totally Off the
Wall crazy anyway what happened then was
how had he been killed he'd been night
to death wow said to death wow so like
multiple times yeah multiple times God
apparently
when I was out gone
somebody and the gun didn't work
Somebody went and got a knife out of the
kitchen so they tried to shoot him they
tried to shoot him but the gun didn't
work apparently
and then somebody put a knife into
Reggie's hands
but he had a lot to drink he was on
tablets
on on purple arts and uh
Jen
I just totally off the wall and uh so
I go upstairs I get the idea down we go
downstairs
I put maybe his body on the idle down
around him and I got in the kitchen I
get some socks
because our dabs dabs her fingerprints
are going to be all over the place
and so I gave him a pair of socks Ronnie
bender and I had a pen we put him on and
we had a right tidy up put them on your
hands yeah and in the meantime there's a
knock on the door
go upstairs
Ronnie Bender he comes back down his
Tony's with him
Tony's come back looking for me
he's got the reason he's looking for the
car my car ain't there
he's come back down to wherever in Road
nine I'd look for him
and so now he's
he's involved up to his eyeballs he
helps us we get the place all tied it up
another knock on the door blonde Carol
and George have come back
where's the planning
come on this isn't Agatha Christie
this isn't kind of you know Stephen King
kind of stuff
this is what it is
total
if there's a comedy there is there's a
tragedy of errors and this was the
tragedy of errors but it's only just
beginning
so
I tell Carol look go in the bedroom and
because it's been a bit of an
altercation things have been sorted out
and everything's okay
she's in there we get the body upstairs
in the hallway
but face in this
is a an all night place where people go
and buy their bagels the cab drivers and
stuff like that
so we've got to wait until there's a
clear
uh what's the name of no taxis there so
we can get the cut get the body out and
get it in the Mac for his car
you can't get a six foot man into the
boat of a car
so we got him on the back seat
but I asked Ronnie Bender what is what
is
you know what his instructions were
and he said that the twins had told him
to get the body carried out to a Railway
Bridge which is about 100 yards away and
throw it over the Railway Bridge
and the train would mash it up
it's it just gets worse and worse and
worse and when you say there is
instructions for disposing of the body
yeah was it normal that the craze would
carry out acts like that or would they
usually have people that would do them
for them no no
no there was nothing ever professional
in any of their their killings when you
think about it
I mean George Cornell
to walk into a pub in front of I mean I
didn't even know and when it happened
but they walked into a pub and the next
thing you know
they shoot a man dead in front of a
barmaid in front of other staff in front
of people enjoying their pint and the
next thing you know and walk out like
nothing's happened on Earth I'm thinking
everybody's gonna keep quiet
an iditra period of time
but eventually
it starts leaking out and so you know
that was another senseless one so for
you at that point in time would you have
described yourself based on what you
what where your life was at that point
in time would you have described
yourself as a violent person were you
involved in a lot of violence no if
something was personal it was personal
right so was this quite a shocking thing
for you it was for me this wasn't
business as usual because it didn't
decision business yeah this is madness
it's what you don't do Ben you
understand what I mean if if you can
read any crime book you want you can
read about the mafia you can read about
Colombian crime they don't do this kind
of thing
they don't put themselves on offer so
why would the craze
you're asking me that
I love the publicity wow
they they wanted it out there
you understand what I'm saying they
wanted it out in the world the
information for me and everything they
had a man right in the book
during the time
of their arrest and everything else like
that it couldn't have come together
but what a waste of two human lives
because they wasn't all bad I mean there
were some good they had some good
qualities
you understand me that's some caring
they love their mum
but just
not enough to stay out of prison
not enough so she didn't have to go and
visit him a year after year after year
and watch him slowly dying
and that's what they did all three died
in prison
is it is it is it a successful
organization
did they sit in a board room at the
Hilton
or wherever
did they do that Bible and have an
office and everything else like that
and people sat down and talked and
discussed and found ways forward
and put ideas to each other no they
didn't
yeah to be what they wanted their way
and their way was total Destruction
and look where it got them at the end of
the day okay so they'd ordered for the
body to be thrown off the bridge but it
didn't but it didn't and why didn't that
happen so what happened was
that we decided
um the three of us that we take the body
over the other side the water
so the the what happened didn't happen
in the East End happened in South London
it couldn't go on the Richardsons or
them because they were all they were all
gone away
they were in prison
so we could put it over there and it
could be anybody he was over there he
got drunk he had a row or whatever it
definitely didn't happen in the west
east end The Craze never thought about
that
we thought about that and that's what we
did we took it through the tunnel
um over the other side of the tunnel it
run out of petrol the car outside of
church
confetti on the on on the uh on on the
pavement and everything else where
there'd been a wedding on that Saturday
um I thought we couldn't happen a better
place because if the people had come out
the church and maybe someone look in the
car and the body will be found and
it it'll all come to light that
something happened over in South London
I looked in the paper the next day
nothing
I looked in the paper again nothing
for the for that week nothing happened
there was no known
and I found that strange
but according to
you know people's stories and everything
else because everybody's told the story
um they got in touch with certain people
and asked them to remove it
and
more people were involved
so you'd left the body in the car
outside the church and they then
subsequently got in don't they for
people they knew where it was right they
would we didn't tell them I think Ronnie
Bender told them right told Charlie
and Charlie got in touch with them
and it had been left on somebody else's
manner right and it was a danger to the
person all the people where it was
we got rid of
and that's what happened okay and the
bodies to this day has never been found
is that right that's right so it was
just removed taken away and buried or
disposed or whatever or whatever okay
just dropped out a c or it could be
anything nobody knows okay
only the people involved no
how can they be that how can I put it
that
thoughtful
but then it wasn't them was it it was
somebody else
who had to make the decision what
happened to that body
you understand me
because if it was them they'd have some
crazy thing would have happened there'd
have been a car crash or there'd have
been something else or maybe I chucked
over him on a railway line I I just
don't know because none of it makes any
sense
um you can't rationalize it
so at the end of the day
um
the police
arrested all the cry firm so how did the
police know I didn't arrest me but how
did they know to start arresting The
Craze what happened was it was
nippery
I mean he'd been after him a period one
time apparently he was a police he was
an inspector raising charge of the case
and he began to look into things
and he began to talk to members of their
firm
and he made one of two threats but also
offered to give a mill up and what have
you if they helped him
and of course one or two of them
relented
and it it won't one or two it was a lot
and so
that's what happened he built a case up
and he was looking at three cases and
one was the McBee
one was the Cornell and one was the
Mitchell murder
um
and I mean Mitchell was a friend of
theirs they got him out of jail
now
I'll ask you a question
if you get a friend out of jail
if you can't do no more for him you let
him go and do whatever he has to do
he stands on his own two feet
you don't kill him
but that's what happened
you know it was
is that believable
sounds chaotic it sounds chaotic what is
the Cornell murder sound like
um what's to make video murder line
chaotic all the way let down the line so
you the the the kind of the image in
popular culture that's been passed on
and sort of created about the cray twins
now is kind of you know east end honor
Amongst Thieves Robin Hood style
gangsters yeah that's right the pa the
picture that you're painting at the
moment is quite different to that it's
the truth yeah it sounds quite sort of
yeah chaotic and um
it sounds like the evidence is there in
itself and when you actually look at the
kind of you look at the arrests
and you have a look at the murders
themselves yeah
is it is it sensible or is it methioso
style to go and take a man or go to a
party in front of a room full of people
kill him
how can you get away with it yeah
there's going to be a weak link there
somewhere
they're going to tell somebody who's
going to tell somebody who's going to
tell somebody tell somebody
and their life was one of paranoia
they didn't trust anybody
but why because of their own their own
self most of the firms in London I know
most of them
they were solid
they were they were ring fenced they
didn't let anybody in they kept things
to themselves
did something it was done they walked
away nothing was said you understand
what I'm saying
they were they were professionals I
suppose as he described the fact that
the mcvitty the mcvitty body has never
been found that's right which was
organized by a different firm different
firm and that's then and the fact that
the body was moved from the house away
from the scene of the crime
onto another manner
space itself somebody else yeah give
some thought to it so when they when
they started to be so nippery the
detective who was trying to yeah the
craze he spoke to members of their firm
and they basically started to give up
the fact that the the twins had murdered
Jack mcvitt no no the Cornell right okay
yeah because he got into the bar maid
right who said she didn't know nothing
of that but she didn't understand it
but according to what I'd heard was she
was threatened that her children would
be taken off of her and all the rest of
it right okay or she could have a safe
house right
oh she should have chose a safe house
and that's exactly what she did and she
gave evidence and then other names came
into it and so on and so forth and
nippery began to build a picture up of
it all
they didn't know nothing about me I
weren't on the radar were you nervous no
I wasn't because I thought they were
sensible people I thought that they
could they control situations and all
that
but when I look at it all
they had no control over nothing um
you know and the people around them
didn't have any control
every everything just came apart their
own cousin stood and pointed the finger
at them
he was the one who went and got the
knife and put it in Reggie Gray's hands
did he serve one day in prison no he
didn't
he went away
so what led up to you being arrested
then so what real adopted me to be
arrested was I was in Birmingham
and uh
the police I was going down to a place
called The Elbow Room
and all of a sudden I was surrounded by
police cars
and they took me to a Snow Hill Police
Station
and uh there for a period of time
they then
something funny happened
um
that afternoon I'd met a young lady
and we got invited to a house
and it turned out to be one of the chief
inspectors of Birmingham police force
but she was his yeah daughter
wow okay that's a connection so when I'm
in Birmingham police station I said what
am I doing now
and one of them said conversions out of
season
so I thought it was over there
anyway they got me in the car and they
took me back to London
but they never took me to Scotland Yard
they took me to a place called tintajo
house on the other side of the
embankment you know where the house of
parliament are facing the house of the
parliament oh yeah yeah there's a place
called tintajo house
and took me out there
and I went into this room
and what I noticed was
say behind us is a blank wall there were
pictures of all the firm there pictures
of the twins
pictures of magni of Cornell and so
consequently
um I knew some it was serious
and so nippery said to me Chris we know
he didn't have nothing to do with it
and we know you left
would you like to tell us about it um
we promise you you nor none of your
family would be arrested
we want to know we will know what you
know
and we know you left
but we know something happened
did you go a party in every Road
I should have done what you're talking
about
they said we've got the craze
we've got their fern
and a lot of their firmware on our side
now tell us about it
I said I can't tell you what I don't
know I have not been to any party
because
that's my education from approved school
to Boston to detention center to prison
you understand what I'm saying you don't
say nothing
that was a culture of the East End you
don't say nothing
you know and that way you can't drop
yourself in it and so consequently
um he turned around he said look
after the interview he said
there's my card
think about it give me a call
I mean the man was trying to
to get me out of it you understand what
I'm saying
but I couldn't do it
so anyway the outcome of it all was
I left tint as your house and I'll call
it the cab and went home
and I thought well I'll go get that
Violet know what's going on
what I've seen the the crazed man yeah
so I went to Bunnell Road where they
lived
and um
not on the dawn Violet came at the door
but a girl called Carol
who was Reggie's girlfriend
and I said well I said I need to speak
to you come in Chris nice to see you and
everything else
and I said look
the preacher brought me down from
Birmingham
um that take me to a place called since
had your house
and they've got photographs of the Twins
and all the firm
certain people who have been done and
what have you
would you let the twins know what I've
seen and what I've told you
I said that and you know wish him luck
anyway
I've
got to walk out and [__] Chris please
everybody's deserting them please open
please she said we're going up there in
an hour's two's time would you come with
us
I said no
and I looked at her and I saw my own
mother
[Music]
a mother cared about her sons
and she felt they had no friends
everybody had left them and deserved
them and to all intents and purposes Ben
that is exactly what happened they'd
started to just abandon them abandon
them yeah
because a lot of people didn't like them
they suffered them
but they didn't you know they were
seeing the stroke pullers they were seen
as people had done nasty things and
everything else like that stroke pillars
did you say yeah stroke pullers what
does that mean well stroke means you
pull a stroke I mean if somebody goes
out and have a robbery and they find out
about it they go and they pull a stroke
we want our share right
you understand me yeah
so they weren't loved in the East End
so if there'd be anything else they they
wanted a share of what other people had
had and so at the end of the day you
know they
they paid for it all themselves and so
reluctantly I went to the crazy it seems
I'll listen to Violet I went to Brixton
and as soon as I walked in Charlie
Christ saw me and he went
shouldn't be a Chris
you should not bear
I knew that
but tell that to a mother who thinks
that her boys have got not not a friend
in the world
and so
I want to saw him and I said look this
is what's happened you know I've seen
this it's on the wall and it looks to me
like they've got quite a bit against you
so you know you know what you're dealing
with you're up against it
thanks for coming Chris you're wondering
the few have even made any effort and I
said well I did it for your mum
because she's kind of you know broken
about everything
and so I left there
and I can still remember
that poor lady she had a handkerchief
and around
wiping the tears from her eyes
and so did old Charlie you're
understanding these These are parents
they're going through it alone
they haven't got messes of people around
him ain't no matter
it's
it's just a mom and dad
anyway I left them and I went back to
Birmingham
I was up there maybe
two weeks
and the police came for me again
brought me down to to tow your house
nippery was sitting there
and he said I gave him my card
why don't you get in touch with me
it's nothing I can tell you
he said why did you go to Brixton
I said
I went to Silence of Christ
he said you want to be part of them
I said no I was I don't be part of
anybody
then tell us
I can't tell you what I don't know I was
at no party I don't know what you're
talking about and he was sitting behind
a desk like the old school teachers desk
playing with a gun A gun
yeah
pistol when he come round and smacked me
over the head with it
and I thought you're just doing that to
get a reaction out of me I ain't gonna
react to this
because I know if I react you've got me
for something
and he turned around and said
you want to be with him
you're going to be with him charging
with murder
to inspect Dakota and kite said murder
he said yeah charge him
and that's what they did they charged me
with murder
took me to uh
by Street magistrates Court put me in a
cell
I heard some people talking
and one of them was Ronnie Bender
and then my brother Tony
so although the cray film have been next
previous to that
me Ronnie bender and tyranny they had
not arrested
and we were arrested
and we appeared in front of both stream
magistrates Court
there was uh
Ronnie Reggie Charlie
Ronnie Bender myself Connie White Ed
and Johnny Barry
or won the Barry Brothers
and
surprised me he was a guy called Freddie
Foreman I'd never met him before
and I thought well what's he doing here
so there were more people getting
involved
that had no part in it all
and that's what I that's what I'm
talking about total chaos
total chaos
anyway we went before when the
longest murder trials in criminal
history
[Music]
um
they they joined two uh murder trials
together
they joined the mcvitty murder and the
Cornell murder
so Ian Barry who had nothing at all to
do
with the mcvitty murder
sat in the same dock as us
on the Cornell murder
and we who had no dealings or knew
anything about the Cornell murder
sat in the dock
through the Cornell murder so you were
kind of collateral damage to the that's
right that's right that's what it was
all about
and I'm pleased you recognize that Ben
so what happened then was
there were differences
um
insults being thrown by running cry at
the at the prosecution Parish that
and
I can remember you know they want to put
numbers around their neck
like we were cattle
and we ripped them all up and threw them
down on the floor
because
you know we didn't we weren't it weren't
a normal trial
um
why should we stand there with numbers
on
we'd not been convicted we'd not been
found guilt we but were you expecting
the
I mean you know how did it work back
then as in were you expecting the the
twins to say no no he had nothing to do
with it I think that's what we we
expected I I don't know that we expected
that but what we expected I suppose was
them to have an answer hmm
to have a plan B
they didn't have anything
they had nothing and and they said to
Albert Donahue apparently turned against
them well you'll take that murder case
and you'll take you you'll take the
Cornell you'll take the macv
to Ronnie r and all these people turned
the Glenstone
you understand what I mean that was
their gown plan
it weren't to get anybody else out
if they were going to go down everybody
else was going to go down with them
he you thought that they'd done
something that they didn't because they
needed the firm
or I firm
it's the only way that Cornell murder
comes up
the tour there so to get the evidence
for the Cornell murder
uh in this young woman got in the dark
the bar made the blind bagger
he's like listen or an angel speak
clear precise
but slightly intimidated
protective of her children
you know
everything she saw
was as clear as a bell you understand
and so
she convicted every one of us
although she did not give evidence
nothing to do with her
it didn't happen even remotely near the
separation of the time and everything
else like that
but she when she got in that dock
that was it forget about Ronnie Hart and
Albert Donahue they were all as crimsex
firms you understand what I mean they
were trying to get themselves out of it
and all the rest of it
and we all went down
and you went down for murder I went down
the murder yeah it's got 15 years
how did that feel my brother Tony went
down for 15 years Ronnie Bender got 20
years why did Ronnie Bender get more
than you uh because they said he was
more involved so how did that remember
I've not done that yeah yeah you
understand but how did it feel knowing
that you and your brother were going
down for something that you didn't do
I'll tell you what it felt like
it felt like
being stood against the wall
and
you've got rifles pointing at you
and you're going down
I felt like them men
who stood in front of a German foreign
Squad
I felt I knew what I thought like
hopeless
destroyed
yet there was always a glimmer of hope
there was always a glimmer that they
might do something
never ever did
so how did you manage through that time
how did you keep yourself sane saying
initially fighting the system
fighting the system
I finished up in Parkhurst Hospital
badly beaten up but I asked for it I
mean I went by the by the guards of the
yeah you know by the prison officers
yeah what happened was
the um
we I went in the dining room this day
because
the food was atrocious
conditions
were not nice
you you wanted your like you you soap
and your shampoo and stuff like that and
you had to wait to get it and all that
kind of thing
I need it now I didn't need it next week
or whatever
and so I I was kicking against the
system right left in the center
and we decided to have a sit in
and uh we locked the cell up
about six of us in now and one turn
around and said I need to go to the
toilet and he went and he didn't come
back
then another one went down another one
went down none of them come back
a natural government phrase friend of
mine Freddie Samson
he said Chrissy said I'm gonna go down
this I'm going to find out what's
happened
an awkward here fighting and yelling
screaming and I went down I got stuck in
with Freddie
and there were that many they pulled us
down the ground but they didn't they
didn't touch me
they didn't kick me they didn't hit me
with a stick or anything else they
literally pulled me down and they
carried me down the choking block as I
did Freddie and they threw me in a cell
the next morning
the uh
I remember that night the banging on the
doors of this chokey cells it was like
the drums of Hayes
could be heard all over the island
and we were all full of rage and anger
and in the morning
Freddie Samson came out of his door
if you're a piss pot over the screws
and I could hear bang bang bang bang
bang
and I know they'd done him
then Little Roy Powell on the next shot
of me
he came out he did the same
Bang Bang
an eagle kicking
on the last on the Block
I can stay in itself and not come out
all I can be my friends
I can do what they've done
I want to look him in the eye
and I went out and did the same
they pull me down
I got stuck into them
they give me a thorough beating
and I remember it's black and blue
and
chop me in the cell
and in the morning the Chief came round
and he says stand up Rihanna and he said
the governors
yeah man's name was killed before her
and he came in
and he went What's Happening Here I said
like you don't know what's happened
you know exactly what's happened I said
but come on let's finish it off
come on finish it off
you can't you can't hurt me anymore I'm
beyond dirt
yeah I won't raise a fist come on finish
it off he said no you're going to
Parkhurst Hospital
and I said um
no I'm not they said we sent for an
ambulance or and a stretcher
wow so you were really badly beaten I
said no I'm gonna walk
and I said well I did because I wanted
to look at all them screws
that dumped me and I wanted you to think
yeah you know about it didn't you
know but you ain't beat me
you've hurt me
but you haven't beat me
I remember walking and getting in the uh
in in in the prison van
illa Parkhurst Hospital
the Queen's doctor was one of the
doctors on the island
and he came in
and he looked to me and I'd broken a
cheekbone and different things like that
and uh lost a couple of teeth
and he
turned around and said look you're gonna
have to rest up and take it easy and
there was a screw there called comfort
senior office only came in he said look
he said you'd be better off in Broadmore
he said they get visits whenever they
want
there's women there you can dance and
all the rest of it and food's good what
do you think about
going over it I said no I said I'm angry
but I'm not mad
and anyway I did the two weeks there
I went over to uh
Albany on the Isle of Wight and I got
back into the into the cell
and everybody's going we won we won we
won
uh and these Cruz came and said to me
get yourself together
you're being moved
next thing I know I was up in Hull
our prison
they moved me away didn't win nothing
didn't win nothing
battled bruised her
I didn't care
I was beyond pain
the pain I had was inside of me
you understand physical pain didn't
didn't do nothing it was a relief more
than anything else
from the pain that was deep deep the
loss of my daughter a young baby I'm not
allowed to see her I'm not allowed to
hold her
I've done it nobody else has done this
did I need to get a kick in now when I
chose to get a kick in I chose to throw
a piss pot over the screws you
understand what I mean
and if I had that done I mean I'd want
to do the same as they did to me you
understand what I'm saying that's the
real world you can't go blaming it Tom
dickinery you've got to accept
responsibility for everything you've
done so the first half of my life I
accept total responsibility and I paid
for everything in one go
and all the bad stuff I've done
that 15 years what the Slate clean
but it didn't because inside of me was
this person who kind of
I knew I was better than that
I knew there was somebody decent inside
of me I'd come from decent parents
you know believers
it was people of conviction
and
I remember I was about seven years in
the sentence
and a guy called Stuart Brown a mate of
mine Scotch guy he gave me a load of
books
and I put them under the bed
and this night
I just couldn't handle it anymore
Ben the blood was running cold and hot
through my veins
and our voice was saying kill yourself
you're never going to get out
this is it this is as far as you can go
you've done seven years look back
now look forward what is there you've
got absolutely nothing
it's a wasteland
you have run through your life you've
decimated everything that's been decent
in it you've done it nobody else
end it
and if a scooter walked in that door
I might have tried to justify being
there
thank God and I really did
so I thought you can't think like this
this raging blood this anger this pain
is
deep down
Madness
and I went through these books I've got
them out
crime
you know people's life stories and all
the rest of it
and there was a Bible
and I picked it up and I threw it away
only time I'd ever had a Bible was when
I ripped a page out being a Catholic
they don't give you a Bible they tell
you what to think never had it in my
life
but I had at it and I ripped Pages out
and roll cigarettes up because the
paper's very very thin and so although I
hadn't read it I smoked it and so you
know at
also
no and I went through the books again
and I'm going to pick the Bible and I
thought
people have climb mountains
people overcome tremendous burdens and
pain
and they've survived and this this book
they've stood on
can I get anything from it
and I thought if I lay down and I put it
under my pillow
the good thoughts
or or going on my head
and I'd read many many stories of people
that were desolate
were lost were broken
and they'd make this man Jesus
but I didn't think anything like that
could ever happen to me happen to them
not for me though
nothing happened
and so I remember
I it's now about four o'clock in the
morning half past four
I'm tired
I I just don't know nothing on
that I've got this rage
and I took the book
and I put it there
by Your Heart by my heart
and the world changed that day
I fell asleep
and I woke up
I've got the Bible and I'll put it down
the front of my trousers
I needed that book wherever I went
and if anybody had asked me what are you
doing with that book
once you've got that book down your
trousers
I could say well in case anybody comes
at me with a knife
I've got that there as protection
it was nothing like that at all
it was something deeper the final thing
I want to ask you is
you know you've had a very unique life
yeah what's it taught you you know
what's your big life lesson that you've
learned
laughs
in the darkness there is always a light
you know if you want to do something
plant a tree
you can sit underneath it in the shade
you can watch it grind develop
you can share it love and
care
and when she's doing that
you're also receiving it what you give
in this world is what you get and I can
remember a dream I had and the dream was
I I was in a garden
and the garden was my life
and I'd run through that Garden
I pulled up the flowers the plants the
bushes the trees
and destroyed them all I decimated it
that was my life
the people that love me
the people that cared
the people I trusted the people you know
trusted me and that belief in me
are destroyed it all
well now I've got my garden back again
I've got some lovely things in it I've
got some I've got my disappointments
but you know I can deal with them
because
instead of judging people
you judge yourself could I have done
something good there could I have helped
that person
it's not always about me
it's about us
collectively we can do something
we can do it on our own
be so good when we all come together we
all need each other
God bless great message thanks so much
for your time Chris and you've been
thank you brilliant yeah I couldn't have
done it with anybody else better
you allowed me to speak God bless you I
hope right after the winter
and occasion it was going to shoot me oh
wow that's exactly awful yeah so he just
called you over yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and and as always so as I let in as
I was bending down to see space I see
him pulled a gun up